part of what is a real opportunity and
executive education is to hear from
other people in the program who have had
similar experiences different
experiences whether it's from a
different country a different industry
with a real wonderful synergy that
exists we're in like a negotiation class
I talk first about the negotiation
process itself
what is negotiation beyond an
adversarial win-lose kind of dynamic and
not only value creation but value
claiming and then we negotiate and I use
the results as the basis for the
discussion for developing a framework
for how can they be more effective in
their negotiations it was very important
for me to get a little bit more insight
in some of the unconscious issues doing
negotiations I take the results and then
we talk about the failures and the
successes and the end we develop a whole
series of prescriptions about how they
can be more effective in different types
of negotiation situations
I have teams in five different countries
and seeing the differences between
different people and their attitude
towards negotiations was very important
for me I also focus on the
counterintuitive findings when honesty
is not the best policy or sometimes when
you don't want to let them see you sweat
or maybe you do want to let them see you
sweat are an answer to a question that
really perplex us a lot
who should make the first offer and if
you want to know any of those answers
need to go